The two on the left are Jonah,
Jonah,
and the whale.
So the story of Jonah is an interesting
one.
Oh,
I'll just go over it very briefly.
There's a city and the city is full of
people who are sinful.
What does that mean?
Well,
to sin is an archery term.
It means to miss the mark.
So these are people who aren't oriented
properly and so the city is in a chaotic
state and God tells Jonah that he's
going to go to that city and tell them
just exactly what's up with them.
And Joanie,
thanks.
No,
I'm not going to do that.
And why?
Well,
that doesn't require much explanation.
It's like how popular you are going to
be if you go to a city full of chaotic
people and tell them why they're stupid
did wrong.
It's Joanna.
Thanks.
No,
I'm not going to do that.
I don't care if God's telling me to do
it.
So his conscience is telling him to do
it or his destiny is telling them to do
it or,
or his orientation with higher morality
is telling them to do it.
You can read it any way you want,
and so he thinks,
no,
I'm harping on this boat and I'm getting
as far away from that city as I possibly
can,
and so he does that and then the storm
comes up because God thinks,
no,
you're not getting away.
If I told you to do something,
you're not getting away from it.
A storm comes up.
Well,
what does that mean?
it's easy.
Betray your destiny and see how long it
takes you to be.
Drowning in a storm
will happen immediately,
and of course it will,
because what?
What's calling you to be your best is
exactly the thing that's pushing you
forward,
to manifest yourself most fully in the
world.
It's what you need.
You run away from that.
The boat's going to start to rock very,
very quickly.
When you all know that you know that
perfectly well,
it,
it's hell.
All you have to do is not study for an
exam that you know that's coming up to
see everything.
Start to the storm.
Water start to rise and everything start
to rock.
It's pretty bloody obvious.
So anyways,
he's on this boat and there's a storm
and all of the people on the boat who
who can't quite discriminate chaos from
whether because they haven't
differentiated the world to that degree,
thank.
Oh the boat wouldn't be about to be
swamped if we hadn't.
Some of us had done something stupid and
wrong and there's logic in that,
you know,
you might think,
well God has nothing personal against
you because of the storm,
so you're confusing levels of analysis,
but you've got to give these people some
credit.
So like maybe they didn't do something
stupid,
maybe they didn't caulk the damn boat
properly.
Maybe the ropes aren't in as good as
shape as they might be.
Maybe they weren't paying attention to
the weather when they went out on the
ocean,
you know?
Or maybe they haven't made peace with
their brother and so their hearts are
bent,
twisted out of shape.
So they don't make particularly good
sailors.
It's like the idea that you encounter a
storm because you're stupid and wrong.
Is it really good idea?
Even though it's not an infinite
applicability anyways,
they draw lots.
It's a primitive thing to do.
It's like,
wow,
it's one,
it's someone's fault.
We don't know who we're going to throw
someone overboard.
The worst sinner.
Obviously that's what God wants.
Some kind of sacrifice.
So they all draw lots and someone loses
and then Jonah stands up and says,
well,
sorry guys,
like I know that I've got a problem with
God at the moment so it's probably me.
You better throw me over and they don't
really want to.
But he finally convinces them over.
He goes,
and that storm settles.
Well,
you know,
sometimes if you're in a group of people
in an organization,
there is someone in the organization
who's head is screwed on exactly
straight and they know exactly why it is
and what they've done wrong and what
puts them in that position and they are
poisoning the entire enterprise and if
you throw them overboard or better,
if they agreed voluntarily to leave,
then this storm will abate and
everything will be okay.
So anyways,
they throw joe job over or Jonah
overboard and a whale comes up and
swallows them and take them down to the
bottom of the ocean.
Well,
we already know what that means because
we watched Pinocchio.
It's like when God abandons you because
you've abandoned your destiny and the
storms come up,
the probability that you're going to be
taken down to the,
to the depths is extraordinarily high,
and that happens in people's lives all
the time.
Also down there,
Jonah repents.
Well,
what do you do when you were in the
underworld?
When you've been there before,
when things fall apart on your friends
have abandoned you.
You're not as popular as you could be.
You can't stand to look at yourself in
the mirror into the underworld.
You go and you think,
Geez,
I've done a lot of things wrong.
You know,
maybe I should reconcile myself with the
world that I could get out of this wall.
So that's what Jonah does.
He thinks,
all right,
I've got this destiny.
I better go do what God says.
So the whale spit some out onto the
beach and off he goes to the city to
tell them what's wrong.
Well,
that's what that represents.
That's these symbols.
You know,
it's so cool.
This second one,
I really,
I really like.
It's so interesting because you see
Jonah and reemerging from the whale and
he's got a halo around his head and you
say,
well,
what's a halo?
Have you ever looked at a quarter?
Well,
think about a quarter.
A quarter is the moon and who's on the
quarter?
The Queen,
the queen is surrounded by the halo of
the Moon,
the Queens Queen of the Queen of the
night gold coin.
That's the king's head on the sun.
That's the halo.
Well,
what comes out of the belly of the fish?
It's the illuminated human being.
It's the spirit of the illuminated human
being.
That's what that means.
Well,
what does that mean?
what else would come out of chaos?
You know,
if you,
if you fall apart and then you put
yourself back together,
what is it that comes back out?
At least you're in better shape than you
were before,
you know,
and then maybe you do that 20 times in
your life or 50 times and you do it
voluntarily.
Every time you do it,
you're more like the thing with the halo
and less like the thing that's being
thrown overboard by your friends.